well coming change in u.s presidents
could also entail significant changes in
u.s foreign policy
justice tensions are spiking in the
middle east that has many in israel
worried
earlier today the country has warned its
citizens against travel in the gulf
region
as iran is seething over the
assassination of its top nuclear
scientist blaming the killing
on israel now with its staunch ally
leaving the white house
the jewish state could face tougher
times
it's been four good years for israeli
conservatives
with a u.s president who often gave them
what they wanted
today i repeat i just want to say thank
you for everything you've done for the
state of israel
you've been the greatest friend that
israel has had in the white house
one of the trump administration's first
foreign policy moves was to recognize
jerusalem as israel's capital
like many actions to come it was
controversial palestinians consider east
jerusalem the capital of a future state
the trump administration also recognized
israeli sovereignty over the contested
golan heights region
captured by israel in 1967 from syria
you can't stand here and stare out at
what's across the border
and deny the central thing that
president trump recognized that previous
presidents had refused to do
that this is a part of israel the
central part of israel
under trump israel aggressively expanded
its settlements in occupied palestinian
territory on the west bank
the u.s has taken steps to legitimize
those settlements
as israeli land one winemaker in a
contested settlement
was so happy he named a wine after
pompeo
us diplomacy also cleared the way for
agreements between israel and long-time
foes the united arab emirates and
bahrain
they came together over a common enemy
iran which has long been considered an
existential threat by israeli
governments
the trump era saw the u.s walk away from
the iran nuclear deal
which was meant to relieve sanctions on
tehran in exchange for strict controls
on its nuclear program
but netanyahu bitterly opposed it saying
it would allow tehran to build nuclear
weapons
without interference
last week a senior iranian nuclear
scientist was killed in an ambush on
iranian territory
tehran has blamed israel and the u.s
protests in iran followed with tensions
so high
it may be more difficult for the
incoming u.s administration
to re-enter the nuclear deal
as an end to the trump era that would
suit some on the israeli right
just fine
[Music]
well joining me now the studio is jeremy
assarov israel's ambassador
to berlin thank you very much uh for
coming in today
my pleasure u.s president-elect joe
biden has said he wants to
re-enter the iran nuclear deal that's a
deal that is supported by germany as
well the eu
by russia and china but opposed by
israel so what is israel going to do
about this
look i think one of the most important
things is to recall what he said
yesterday evening about the bottom line
being to stop iran getting a nuclear
weapon and that has always been our
goal i think it's always been germany's
goal and it's always been the goal of
the p5 plus one
and the nuclear agreement the question
is how do you achieve it and one thing
we've seen over the last months is very
clear
string of iranian violations of the
jcpoa whether in terms of the amount of
enriched uranium
the level of enriched uranium the use of
advanced centrifuges
so a whole string of violations
alongside a very energetic
and active missile program as well as a
continued destabilizing activity
in the middle east in general but so are
you saying that the
the the nuclear deal is not the right
instrument to achieve that goal
i'm saying that it's been seen that the
nuclear deal as it was drafted in 2015
has been shown to have uh lacuna and
gaps
which need to be addressed and clearly
the
the steps taken by the iranian
government to violently
to destabilize the middle east in
general
continue their missile program and
violate the actual
clear terms of the nuclear agreement
provide us with no confidence that
the agreement is working what would what
would provide you with confidence then
well i think first of all look let's be
uh
adjust ourselves to the present
situation there's a there will be
there's a transition in washington uh
and obviously
a new american administration will have
to address this
it'll take time to appoint the teams and
the policies
to have consultations with partners like
with europe
and also i would imagine also with
israel so i think it'll still take a bit
of time to come
and put the policy actual policy
together so the deal is not dead you're
saying
i i look we need to have an effective
diplomacy
which prevents iran getting a nuclear
weapon and that in my view is very much
dependent on these consultations that
will happen in the
in the weeks and months ahead to put
together an effective and vibrant policy
that will secure
that goal well this week a top iranian
nuclear scientist was assassinated
tehran
uh blames the attack on israel what's
your comment
uh look you know iran blames israel for
virtually every
ill in the middle east and uh and from
that point of view i think it's more
important to keep
an eye on what iran is doing and again
you're not denying it but you're not
confirming it i'm not relating to it at
all
they might have their speculations and
uh
you know we've seen a number of times
where they've said things that have
proven to be uh
untrue particularly in terms of what
they are supposed to be doing
in terms of complying with the nuclear
deal but it's a clear setback for iran
when their top scientist
is no longer around some
iran when it continues to pursue a
nuclear
weapons uh uh activity when it continues
to
pursue missile uh development and when
it continues to
interfere in the politics of lebanon
syria iraq
yemen that is the the thing that i think
is the key thing that we need to keep an
eye on
well just today israel has warned its
citizens uh in in the
in the region of an increased threat
from iran
after this attack so what intelligence
is that
warning based on well first of all i
remind our the viewers that about three
weeks ago the iranians
uh placed uh um improvised elect
explosive devices on our border on the
golan heights in the southern part of
the golan heights
and we identified this and we responded
so this is a very
ongoing problem that we face vis-a-vis
iran
we face iran's involvement in syria we
face it
it's also in lebanon it's support of
hezbollah providing hezbollah with very
extensive weaponry
so you know this is uh you know this is
an ongoing
problem that we have an ongoing threat
which is
not just an abstract thing it happens on
the ground
so i mean obviously at this time we're
taking every precaution possible
in every possible way and and this is uh
this is something that we're being very
clear about
as an ambassador to germany can germany
and the eu
help maintain stability uh in the middle
east and and
with regard to iran especially well
first of all i think they can and
it's i think it's been very interesting
that the first two visits of the israeli
foreign minister gabi ashkenazi
abroad after the new government was
established was to germany was to berlin
the first to meet with heiko massi's
counterpart who we see is a great friend
of israel
and who just also recently improved
germany's voting record in the u.n he
also met at the same time with 26 other
foreign ministers of europe
and the second time he came he met with
his uae counterpart
uh for the first bilateral and
trilateral meeting
between uh between us so i think this
was uh
this was a very clear example of how
germany can contribute to the
new paradigm shift the process of
normalization and peace in the middle
east
which is happening as opposed to the
more negative uh
threats that we've discussed before
jeremy sacharov
israel's ambassador to germany thank you
very much for joining us here on dw news
today thank you very much